[Musique]
bonjour à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos le magazine
consacré à l'actualité économique de
notre territoire sans plus tarder voici
le sommaire focus dans ce numéro sur le
concept de smart city ou villes
intelligentes saint quentin en yvelines
est engagé dans cette démarche
plusieurs innovations sont déjà
présentes sur notre territoire pour
aller plus loin dans ce thème nous
recevrons martial chevreuil directeur
business innovation chez egis et julien
fessard présidente de m to m
retour sur le rendez vous annuel de
l'immobilier d'entreprise à paris le
simi plus de 460 exposants étaient
présents parmi eux des collectivités
comme le département et saint quentin en
yvelines
enfin nous ferons un point sur le reste
de l'actualité économique dans notre
région avec notamment le budget 2010 est
de l'île de france ou encore une
entreprise yvelinoise qui met ses
clients au coeur de sa politique
commerciale pour les fêtes de fin
d'année une fois n'est pas coutume nous
n'allons pas ouvrir ce magazine avec un
chiffre mais avec des lettres a à moin
lé agences de notation standard and
poor's vient de maintenir cette note
pour saint quentin en yvelines
seul à consolider la bonne santé
comptable du territoire comme le précise
le communiqué de l'agglomération le
recours à ce type d' agences de notation
est encore très peu utilisée par les
collectivités territoriales ces notes
ont notamment pour but de rassurer les
investisseurs et les banques
retour à présent sur un salon qui s'est
déroulé du 6 au 8 décembre dernier au
palais des congrès de paris c'était la
16e édition du 6 me un salon entièrement
dédié à l'immobilier d'entreprise
un rendez vous annuel auquel ont
participé saint quentin en yvelines et
le département des yvelines
objectif montrer que ces territoires
sont attractifs pour les entreprises
c'est au coeur du stand de paris saclay
que saint quentin en yvelines présente
ses atouts
accueil de la ryder cup en 2018 mais
aussi sa bonne forme en matière de
transactions immobilières pour l'année
en cours
4 6 millions de mètres carrés
d'immobilier d'entreprise un taux de
vacance à 6 7% ou encore 250 mille
mètres carrés de projets immobiliers en
développement un secteur dynamique
destinée à convaincre les futurs
investisseurs
il est indispensable qu'on soit là qu'on
rencontre tout le monde qu'on voyait
nouveauté les innovations et les
nouvelles propositions comment on peut
être plus rentable être plus plus rapide
être être plus simple parce que c'est
important d'être simple aujourd'hui
telle simplification pour tout le monde
comprenne là on va cette année saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi
versailles grand parc et paris saclay
ont proposé une conférence commune sur
les grands événements internationaux
faire stand commun c'est aussi la
volonté du département des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine
objectif mettre en avant l'attractivité
de ces deux territoires de l'ouest
francilien nous faisons l'aménagement de
notre territoire
la promotion de l'attractivité ensemble
donc avec une force de frappe beaucoup
plus importante avec une efficacité sur
le terrain ou bien meilleur il faut être
là où sont les investisseurs puisque
c'est eux que nous chassons pour porter
du développement dans des codes dans nos
communes dans nos territoires
parce que ce développement crée de la
richesse fiscale et de l'emploi des
enjeux économiques importants donc pour
saint quentin en yvelines et notre
département jusqu'à la fermeture de ses
portes vendredi le salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise devrait accueillir plus de
28 mille visiteurs et lors de cet
événement il était notamment question de
smart cities comprenez et villes
intelligentes un concept d'origine anglo
saxonne qui permet d'améliorer nos modes
de vie saint quentin en yvelines
s'inscrit dans cette démarche une
volonté motivée notamment par de
nombreuses innovations présentes sur le
territoire comme vous allez le voir dans
ce reportage
des films de science fiction qui seront
peut-être bientôt la réalité dans les
prochaines années des nouvelles façons
de se déplacer de travailler ou encore
de consommer tout cela grâce au
numérique avec son université ces
entreprises innovantes et ses centres de
recherche saint-quentin-en-yvelines
compte bien devenir dans un futur proche
une smart city s'est préparé la vie de
demain pas seulement la ville la vie de
nos concitoyens demain qu'ils aient un
maximum de confort de qualité de vie de
sécurité de santé d'accès à tous les
services
fin novembre les élus du territoire et
les membres du cos des skis le conseil
de développement de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont réunis pour mettre en
avant les innovations déjà présente au
sein de l'agglomération
chez renault par exemple on mise déjà
sur le transport connectés autonome et
électriques
les parties sont des villes qui vont
gérer de façon de plus en plus
intelligentes l'énergie et les véhicules
électriques vont participer à la cette
gestion données intelligente de
l'énergie ça c'est respect même chose
pour le transport les futurs hits
solution en fait deux
mobilité que l'on met en place sont des
solutions intelligentes qui vont aider
justement à optimiser les déplacements
par exemple des populations mais aussi
des marchandises intérieur des villes
l'énergie un élément clé dans les
projets de smart cities l'entreprise way
to buy colas basée à magny les hameaux a
développé l'année dernière une route
solaire une première mondiale qui est
encore en phase d'expérimentation et
font des dalles donc qu'ils font à peine
un centimètre d'épaisseur et donc qu'ils
comprennent des cellules photovoltaïques
c'est ce que l'on a ici tous les ans je
travaille donc ça constitue en fait à
pouvoir mettre au point une dalle donc
une structure mécanique qui est cette
zone blanche là qui permet en fait de
pouvoir résister à l'effet du trafic ne
pas trop se déformer du coût limité donc
la déformation de la cellule et donc
éviter sa rupture
cette technologie est actuellement testé
sur plusieurs dizaines de chantiers en
france mais aussi au canada ou au japon
coller directement sur la chaussée les
dalles permettent de produire de
l'électricité
une solution innovante pour les
collectivités qui souhaitent devenir des
villes intelligentes
elle permet donc de pouvoir produire
cette énergie localement de pouvoir
contribuer
à ce que les bâtiments puisse être
énergie positive à pouvoir contribuer à
ce que tous les capteurs puisque
finalement ville intelligente on parle
d'infrastructures mais également des
outils les objets connectés ces objets
connectés vont avoir besoin d'énergie
autre innovation développée par
l'entreprise dédale composé de leds
appelé flow well présenté lors du
dernier salon des maires ce marquage au
sol lumineux permettra d'optimiser
l'espace urbain la fluidité du trafic
mais aussi la sécurité avec ce passage
piéton
et pour aller plus loin sur ce thème
deux invités m'ont rejoint au plateau
martial chevreuil bonjour du jeu vous
êtes directeur business innovation chez
egis dont le siège social est d'ailleurs
à guyancourt un mot rapide sur votre
activité va d'abord sur et jcj c'est un
groupe international d'ingénierie et
aussi le montage de projets et
d'exploitation dans nos mains notamment
dans le domaine de la mobilité nous
sommes treize mille de collaborateurs
plus 13014 l'idée nous intervenons au
niveau mondial on dit souvent que notre
devise un peu une devise que je reprends
souvent à mon compte ces think global
act local et nous sommes aussi
effectivement très impliqué dans le
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines aussi bien sur les sujets de
mobilité que les sujets de bâtiments de
développement des quartiers les
écoquartiers on y reviendra on va en
parler voilà dans quelques instants en
face de vous bonjour vous êtes le
président la start-up end-to-end et vous
êtes un tube et ou au ski cube même
chose présentez-nous en quelques mots
votre votre star tapas vous l'avez dit
on est incubé au sky cub depuis le début
de l'année et on travaille notamment sur
une solution de gestion de l'éclairage
public qui s'appuie sur les technologies
de l'internet des objets justement est
ce qu'on peut nous en dire plus sur sur
cet outil justement qui s'inscrit
j'imagine dans un projet de smart city
oui tout à fait c'est un cetain une
solution qui va pouvoir s'intégrer à la
fois sur une infrastructure existante
mais aussi dans des projets neufs et qui
permet d'amener de la connectivité à des
points d'allumage que ce soit au niveau
des armoires de distribution ou des
lampadaires avec à la fois des données
d'entrée qui sont variables et qui
peuvent provenir des données dont
dispose la commune données routières
donner plus tard des véhicules eux-mêmes
par exemple et pouvoir activer
des senseurs des actionneurs différents
et notamment l'éclairage public en
fonction d'une situation donnée pour
éclairer juste au bon moment car si
achèverait quels types d'outils et j'ai
justement développe dans le cadre d'un
projet smart city alors terme doute
outil on va d'abord parler un peu de
méthode l'habitante city c'est une ville
ils font souvent numérique mais l'anti
tisser intègre à ses pouvoir répondre
aux besoins des citoyens de pouvoir
aussi réduire les consommations les
émissions et tout ça en assurant le
développement de la ville donc c'est
tout de même un proche on développe une
approche systémique ou méthodes
d'ingénierie effectivement et ensuite on
peut utiliser des outils on utilise des
outils de simulation de la ville de des
bâtiments des déplacements et
dissimulation et également de la
consommation énergétique de façon
ensuite à pouvoir voir quelles solutions
peut apporter alors ce puits des
solutions aussi développé par des ordres
des grandes entreprises mais aussi
aujourd'hui de plus en plus par des
start up appliqué on travaille de façon
à rendre la ville
inclusive durable est la moins émettrice
possible en termes de on en parle
aujourd'hui de gaz à effet de serre tout
en assurant le développement économique
car ça le grand défi de la ville
aujourd'hui sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines ces outils sont déjà
sont déjà implantés n'ont pas tous ces
outils mais on a eu l'occasion de
travailler sur des sur des quartiers sur
les bâtiments pour réduire les
consommations on notera voudra eu
beaucoup sur la mobilité depuis très
longtemps on accompagne de saint quentin
et puis on espère aussi bien travaillé
sur le dans le cas des jo de 2024
puisque saint quentin est aussi une
ville qui va accueillir une communauté
qui va accueillir une partie des
épreuves sur les jo on a développé un
certain nombre de solutions innovantes
notamment pour l'heure le réemploi des
bâtiments du village olympique on écrit
qu'après les jo enfin ces bâtiments
soient réutilisées et puis aussi une
solution alors lorsqu'on parle de cela
un sit-in on parle beaucoup aussi de
mutualisation utilisation des ressources
l'utilisation des moyens par exemple des
transports à sa se transporte évident le
covoiturage mais aussi l'espace public
partagé c'est à dire allouer
dynamiquement l'usl de la route
et puis c'est aussi le réemploi des
matériaux et on vient d'ouvrir avec nos
confrères d'icade d'une société c'est
emile bien une plateforme qui va ouvrir
enfin elle va ouvrir en janvier sur le
rend pas des matériaux donc ça sera une
plateforme très ouverte de façon à
justement le minimiser l'impact de
le compte de la construction sur le sur
les gaz à effet de serre une dernière
question julien fessard vous êtes donc
vous implanter un sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines en quoi
justement c'est un territoire idéal pour
être devenir une smart city dans l'est
dans les prochaines années
eh bien je pense que comme le reportage
la montre et c'est un territoire très
dynamique qui est tout de même assez
tendue avec une forte volonté politique
d'aller vers l'innovation
donc nous en 2018 notre objectif pour
cette solution
c'est d'effectuer des expérimentations
en temps réel et d'aller repousser les
limites actuelles en tout de suite étant
efficace grâce à ces nouvelles
technologies
merci messi en tout cas nous avoir
apporté cet éclairage sur ce sujet la
smart cities le budget 2010 8 de la
région ile de france une entreprise
saint-quentinoise racheté par un groupe
lyonnais est une enseigne yvelinoise qui
mise tout sur la satisfaction de ses
clients
c'est tout de suite dans les courants
bref des investissements en hausse tout
en restant une des régions les plus
économes de france voici comment on
pourrait résumer le budget 2010 8 de
l'île de france
plusieurs objectifs pour l'année
prochaine devenir la première région
écologique d'europe avec notamment 732
millions d'euros d'investissements dans
les transports mais aussi rendre la
région plus attractive au service de
l'emploi 780 millions d'euros seront
consacrés au lycée
près de 570 millions d'euros seront
alloués à la formation professionnelle
et l'apprentissage
en août dernier entreprises tvi
construction basée à voisins le
bretonneux avait été placée en
liquidation judiciaire
elle vient d'être racheté par un groupe
lyonnais tgl groupe spécialisé dans les
domaines de la construction et de
l'immobilier
sur les 380 salariés 213 ont été repris
le groupe lyonnais qui devrait réaliser
270 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires l'année prochaine souhaite
encore plus se développer sur le marché
francilien
[Musique]
cadeau zen ludiques ou cocooning voici
ce que vous pourrez trouver chez nature
et découvertes pour ces fêtes de fin
d'année la société yvelinoise créée en
1990 a fait 208 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en 2016
au delà des valeurs environnementales
qu'elle défend l'entreprise place le
client au coeur de sa politique
commerciale
l'enseigne est très attentive à la
satisfaction des clients
et c'est vrai qu'il ya des enjeux très
fort sur la formation notamment et nos
guides conseils viennent à versailles
pour être formés et c'est très important
de qu'ils soient à l'aise sur les
produits qu'ils apportent un vrai
conseil à nos clients c'est la fin de ce
numéro merci de l'avoir suivi ion se
retrouvent mardi 9 janvier pour un
nouveau 7 8 et qu elles disent il a
passé de très bonnes fêtes
à bientôt
[Musique]